[Music]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whatsa r hi Walton hello
Walter did you
think 10 years ago or 20 years ago that
you will see things happen as it is
unfolding today no we've always been
speculating and thinking about these
things and uh I probably read almost
everything that you can get your hands
on about Daniel and Revelation you know
you have all those heavy theological
Symposium compendiums where all the top
theologians in the world tell you what
they think it says and then what certain
uh pastoral individuals think what it
says and then what lay people think what
it
says and you try and glean something out
of all of it yeah but it's never really
understood until it starts unfolding MH
and uh even when it IT unfolds you might
not have all the facts correct yeah but
if you have a general
picture that you can say well
this fits the biblical profile it does
make
sense uh even though it's not always
easy to categorize or to
understand then uh the time comes when
you put all those things that you said
in the past and where you tried to fit
it in put it into new settings you don't
throw anything out but you you look at
it through different glasses yeah yeah
because prophecy has been unfolding that
continuously yes so that's why it's a
very important discussion which
obviously we haven't discussed in uh or
planned in doing no but God always
brings these things towards and after
that last one where we talked about the
image of the
Beast as it is unfolding and it it is so
crystal clear that it is
unfolding then uh we actually mentioned
that perhaps it's time to revisit some
of the prophecies in the Bible just to
see where we're heading how it's going
to unfold what's going to happen yeah
and uh that's what we try to do now in
this one so for the next two episodes we
will look at the the prophetic
profile and you know what they say at
weddings something pink something blue
Something Borrowed something new or
something like like that something old
something new something borrowed
something blue whatever so you put all
of those things together and just try
and and reset the puzzle the pieces
remain the same exactly it's just the
picture might become clearer I me so
let's pray and open we can't do this
without prayer amen our heavenly
father we stand in awe at the Wonders
that you you portray to us and the
things that we see happening in the
world world as we read them in the Bible
so we ask please enlighten our minds
protect us with your angels and let the
holy spirit guide our discussion in
jesus' name amen
amen we want to talk about a woman that
rides the Beast now we have a backdrop
picture
here and it says a woman rides the Beast
and there's a subtitle the secret
revealed mhm it's a little bit
presumptuous on our part but uh let's be
a little bit
presumptuous now it's pretty clear that
uh this woman portrays something she's
obviously quite a wealthy woman
considering the stones on her hands
she's a bit of a wanton woman a loose
woman
mhm and through her face in the
background you can see uh the Vatican
yeah so she obviously associated with
the
Vatican and uh there's a cross on the
top there and so it's a religio
political system secrecy and mystery and
she's got her eyes closed because uh
there's a secret there there's a mystery
and maybe she doesn't want you to look
into the window of her soul yes because
you might find things there that are
unsavory so let's have a look at this
woman and take a bit of a look at the
whole issue of the
unfolding of the mystery of iniquity in
the Bible yeah because also the devil is
very hard at work to take away the focus
from who the true identity is yes and
he's got so many things out there is it
this one is it that one and uh you know
all kinds of strange
ideas and we must be careful very
careful that we don't build a theology
on a
counterfeit and it can be easy can
easily happen like the Israel story M
that is building a theology on a counter
feet and once you start building a
theology on a counterfeit then you can
get hooked up with Eastern issues and
turkey and all kinds of things the Bible
is very clear as to who the problem is
yeah it's this terrible beast and we
need to Define it once and for all say
who the Beast is and then there are
nuances like the King of the North the
King of the South all of these things
that all play in with this scenario so
let's have a look at it a woman rides
the
beast when the books of Daniel and
Revelation are better understood
Believers will have an entirely
different religious experi
experience they will be given such
glimpses of the open Gates of Heaven
that heart and mind will be
impressed with a character that all must
develop in order to realize the
blessedness which is to be the reward of
the pure in
heart there are a lot of subliminals in
that statement true very much so don't
you think so because if if you look at
it if you understand the books of
Revelation that's facts yeah it'll do
something to the heart it'll give you a
different religious
experience and obviously as they are
better understood means that there is a
progression in understanding yeah as it
unfolds as well yes and if you
understand these books and you see the
mystery of
iniquity and you compare it with the
godliness then you will realize what
kind of character you must develop in
order to go to heaven because this
contrast character will not go to heaven
it goes to pedition
yeah and then you will be impressed as
to what kind of character you must
develop so prophecy even though it is is
facts
unfolding must do something to the heart
must definitely change and for the
better and and if you just
realize that when you are reading and
understanding in Prophecy that you are
dealing with the infallible word of God
it must give you confidence in God's
word isn't that the truth I mean you all
you hear people say that we should
rather not use the Bible and the books
of Daniel and Revelation to try and
prove history this says the exact
opposite exactly and why because through
this you will get gain a better
understanding of how what you how you
should be in relationship to God to get
ready for heaven
correct so with that in mind let's jump
into
it the Beast of Revelation 17 and the
woman that rides it Revelation
17:1 and there came one of the Seven
Angels which had the seven
vials and talked with me saying come
unto me come hither and I will show unto
the the Judgment of the Great Hall that
sth upon many
Waters with whom the kings of the Earth
have committed fornication and the
inhabitants of the Earth have been made
drunk with the wine of her
fornication now the description of the
Beast is not necessarily what we see
here but uh it is a seven headed beast
mhm and and one of the Seven Angels
which had the seven vials was the one
that said come let me show you something
so where are we in the Stream of time
well this must be right at when the pl
just before or when the plagues will
start falling all right so it takes us
to the time of the end yeah that's it
now this Beast is obvious still very
busy so it is before the close of
probation MH but it is close to the end
the angel has already a vial in his hand
to pour out the plague that's a plague
yeah so we've progressed through the
stream of
time and we know that's a woman and we
know that biblically a woman represents
a church yes in scripture and we know
that this church has illicitly aison
with the kings of the Earth with the
rulers of the
world and that they commit fornication
with her in other words they practice
apostasies whereas they should be
practicing what the scripture says
exactly so we have a war it's actually a
war on God's word
yeah and they are drunk with the wine of
a fornication now wine in the scripture
is often a reference to
Doctrine you must you must put new wine
into new wine skins you must it's not
about a wine it's about Doctrine if you
want to understand it you must have a
new heart you must be reborn you must be
new in order to grasp it in order to
understand it but this wine is a
deceptive wine it's it's a false
Doctrine so we know that there is a
woman
mhm that's a church that controls
political systems that's it and and all
the kings of the world are in cahoots
with
her that's the bottom line in this story
and so he carried me away in the spirit
Into the Wilderness and I saw a woman
sit upon a Scarlet colored Beast now
it's interesting that this woman at this
stage in history is in the
wilderness that also shows you where
where in the history where it fits in
yes so she's been taken out of her seat
of direct power and isolated to one side
M but she's still a Wicked Woman yeah
but she is in a Wilderness State that's
it and I saw a woman sit upon a Scarlet
colored piece now we must note that it
is Scarlet because we have to draw
parallels with the Bible to identify yes
so it's a Scarlet colored Beast full of
the names of
blasphemy now where do we find blasphemy
we find blasphemy in Revelation 13 and
we find blasphemy in the little horn
power of Daniel 7 yes and they're all
exactly the same thing just different
phases full of the names of blasphemy
having seven heads and 10
horns all right so this woman is riding
a beast that has seven heads and 10
horns so we have to find the heads and
we have to find the horns yes we have to
go back in history and see where do the
heads come from where do the horns come
from now that you have to go back to
Book of Daniel to find the because it's
a key that's the key and Daniel tells
you where the 10 horns
arise they arise at the fall of the
Roman Empire and there they come up and
amongst them comes another little horn
yes so it's actually 11 horns yeah but
we'll get to
that and a horn according to scripture
is also a political entity or the king
that stands for the political entity
because the Bible defines it it tells
you what it
is and the woman was arrayed in purple
and Scarlet colors and decked with
golden precious stones and Pearls having
a golden cup in her hand full of the
Abominations and Fess of her
fornication now that's a pretty cryptic
clue uh you can't really go wrong with
it it's a very rich woman y as also our
backdrop shows a very rich
woman in fact probably the richest of
all the
churches yeah probably of all entities
all entities on the entire
planet and she has a golden cup in her
hand full of the Abominations and
filthiness of her fornication now Martin
there's only one Church in the
world that depicts herself as a woman
with a golden cup in her hand and that
is the Church of Rome Roman Catholicism
is just a fact so here is a statue in
the Vatican where the woman is holding a
golden
cup that's pretty straightforward she's
not ashamed of the fact that she has the
ear of the kings of the world that's
it's boasting boasting
yes and upon her foret was a name
written mystery now mystery is a secret
isn't it mhm
it's dark you know it's something that's
hidden yeah but it tells us that it's
Babylon the
great so we have a clue it is a
political religious system that has
Babylonian elements in
it and Babylon was always the antagonist
to God's people yeah mother and child
worship comes from Babylon we don't want
to go into all of those details but she
also calls herself the mother of harlots
and Abominations of the earth now if she
herself is a harlot
mhm and she claims that she's a mother
of
harlots that means she's the mother of
other churches that are also in apostasy
yeah daughters and if you are in cahoots
with this woman you automatically become
a harlot because you cannot be you
cannot be in harmony with God if you are
in harmony with her you cannot if you
acknowledge her as a leading
figure then you acknowledge an
Abomination that's what the scripture
says it's a simple that's harsh but
that's what it says all right now we've
we've done many many presentations on
why her teachings on abomination
that's true remember we did one the
doctrine of the serpent that's it and
people can go and look at that we don't
want to repeat all of the doctrinal
errors so this is what scripture says
we've even also shown that the daughters
we've show numerously how they also
drink of or have these Abomination
doctrines and have doctrines which are
unbiblical which comes straight from
this
mother now does she acknowledge that she
is the mother of all the churches we
know that she does yeah here's another
statue of a woman holding the cup in her
hand they're very proud of the fact that
they are the woman with the cup in the
hand this is also in in the Vatican this
is also there now here is the this is
actually the spiritual head of the Roman
Catholic Church not the Vatican that's
more the seat the seat of government if
you like but here is St John's latter
and this is where the pope speaks ex
cathedra from his seat okay so this is
actually Church in state almost yes this
it's a church portion and the seat is
more the okay so this is St John's lran
it's of course also in Rome MH and if
you go to the portals there are two
plaques there where my arrows are
pointing and there she claims that she
is this Eccles
astical entity she is this
ecclesiastical
mother and other words she's the mother
of all the churches and Pope Benedict
made it quite clear when he said we are
not a sister we are the mother and the
other churches are daughters children
not sisters of ours they're daughters so
it is abundantly clear who we are
dealing with in this
prophecy now seven-headed
beasts occur actually only three times
in the scriptures and uh the others are
composits that add up to seven but a
description of seven headed beasts three
times and let's have a look at some of
these descriptions Revelation
12:3 and there appeared another Wonder
in heaven and behold the great red
dragon what was the color of the woman
that wrote the Beast Scarlet Scarlet
it's red right having seven heads and 10
horns and seven crowns upon the heads
now these crowns are on the heads not on
the horns yes okay so we need to know
who this red dragon is revelation 12
also tells us that you know the dragon
is also Satan mhm because he took a
third of the stars with him he took a
third of the Angels out of heaven with
him and there was war in heaven and all
of that description is in Revelation 12
but we'll get to it now
now the second one we come across is
revelation 13 and I stood upon the sand
of the sea and I saw a beast aride out
of the sea having seven heads and 10
horns so it must be associated with this
previous one mhm because it also has
seven heads and 10 horns and you know
there saying if it looks like a duck and
Walks Like A Duck and quacks like a duck
then it's a
duck cannot cannot call it a chicken no
that's what it is it's a
duck so and upon his horns 10 crowns and
upon the head's name of blasphemy mhm
all right so what has happened here the
crowns have moved from the head to the
horns okay so that's so we get to that
so there must have been some progression
took place because there's a movement
that's it and then the third one of
course that we find is Revelation 17 so
he carried me away in spirit Into the
Wilderness and I saw a woman sit upon a
Scarlet colored Beast there you have the
Red Dragon full of names of
blasphemy having seven heads and 10
horns now again you have blasphemy on
this one and you have blasphemy on the
one in Revelation 13 mhm so they're the
same
exactly in Psalm 74 we read this verse
thou breakast the heads doesn't tell us
how many heads there are but it's
plural so not one let's take a guess
it's probably seven
right of latan in pieces and gave us him
to be meat to the people inhabiting the
Wilderness so in other words God says
he's going to destroy this system it's
going to be destroyed but he's
permitting it for a while yeah so let's
just get a little bit more information
so that we can see the
progression of these
beasts so let's look at the one in
Revelation CH 12 and there appeared
another Wonder in heaven Behold a great
red dragon having seven heads and 10
horns and seven crowns upon his head
mhm so each of these heads has a
crown and we need to know what the heads
are and we need to know what the horns
are and we need to know why the crowns
are where they are yeah now I don't
think we want to go through the whole of
Revelation 12 no we've done it we've
done it we're going to concentrate on
Revelation 17 but let's do a little
summary so this seven-headed Dragon
Beast represents Imperial Rome why do we
say so
well it tried to destroy Jesus by
issuing a decree to kill the infants
under two years of age mhm Herod who was
a
Roman uh employee if we shall put it
that way is the one who issued that
decree yeah this power crucified Jesus
and persecuted his church under Pontius
Pilate yeah so it was a Roman issue it
also represents Satan who has made Romey
seat and used this power of to crush all
descent so this is Imperial Rome and the
crowns are on his heads yeah in actual
fact during this Imperial Roman stage
the horns hadn't actually yet developed
but that he's depicted with 10 horns
true we'll see in Daniel that the the
horns came up later that's it that's it
so Rome was
ruling it was yielding Imperial power in
the world yeah
and it was a tool of Satan's his
Masterpiece it was Pagan blatant Pagan
and he used it to crush
Christianity and
Christ and uh so this is the Pagan form
of that
power so when next we come across this
seven added Beast we find it in
Revelation chap 13 the Beast out of the
sea
and I stood upon the sand of the sea and
I saw a beast rise up out of the sea so
obviously it arises amongst the peoples
the Nations the multitudes yes that's
where
okay having seven heads and 10 horns so
it's it's very similar to the one that
we found in Revelation 12
yep and upon his horns the 10 crowns so
the crowns had moved from the heads to
the
horns and upon his head the name of
blasphemy now this is very interesting
now according to Daniel chapter 7 the
first Beast that arises is Babylon yes
Babylon is conquered by me Persia the
symbol used for Babylon is the lion
that's it me Persia conquers Babylon the
symbol used for me Persia is the bear MH
me Persia is conquered by Greek
the symbol that is used is the
foreheaded leopard
beast and then a terrible Beast yes and
10 horns arise and then we're told in
the Book of Daniel that the 10 horns are
10 kings that will arise out of this
Kingdom
mhm but three in are in opposition to
another Power the little horn power yeah
that's growing in up correct so
according to scripture three of them
have to be
unrooted and then the little horn grows
into prominence and becomes more Stout
than all the others and becomes
prescriptive and rules over the Kings
and has blasphemy and it is a
Blasphemous power so this power is papal
Rome yeah so we have a shift from
literal Rome to papal Rome yeah so there
was Pagan Rome to papal Rome correct and
therefore there's a shift in the ruling
power yeah so the crowns the rulership
was on the heads it controlled these
kingdoms and now they're on the horns so
Rome is ruling the powers of Europe yes
papal Rome papal Rome and remember that
it had to uproot three mhm now Martin if
you do a little bit of a
calculation if there were 10 horns and
three were uprooted then how many were
left seven seven so there were seven
horns but amongst them came up another
horn that took prominence or preeminence
if you like overb basically so how many
horns were there eight now now what
number would that horn have then eight
it is eight mhm so the number attached
to that horn is eight correct correct
okay and the Beast which I saw was like
unto a leopard and his feet were as the
feet of a bear and his mouth as the
mouth of a
lion and the dragon gave him his power
and seat and great Authority now the
dragon was in Revelation 12 it
represents the devil but it also
represents Pagan Rome yes did Pagan Rome
historic
give its Authority and its seat of power
to the papal sea yes yes 100% it's to
the yeah the pope became the leader so
according to the decrees of the Roman
emperors from Justinian through to
Constantine this power that Rome yielded
in Rome in the political sphere was
handed over to the papacy yes and the
papacy began to rule as the supreme
power once the opposition of three of
these European nations had been uprooted
yes right yeah the Uli the ostrogoths
and the vandals MH they were removed the
last of them was the ostrogoths yeah and
then he took the papal chair vigorous
ascended the Y was 538 ad and his rule
of
1,260 years commence MH where he ruled
Europe with an iron fist yes the crown
was upon the horns he ruled over the
European powers especially the eighth
horn and he ruled as the eighth horn his
number was eight there were 10 three
were uprooted he grew Mighty he was the
eighth horn and this also this portion
tells you where you are in the history
in the Stream of time so we've had a
progression right now it's interesting
Martin that all the others that were
conquered were conquered by military
power they were
overthrown Babylon was conquered by the
me
Persians the me Persians were conquered
by the Greeks the Greeks were conquered
by the Romans but after this there's no
conquering no there's no war there's no
takeover there is a shift
in emphasis that's all that happens so
once Rome has been established Rome
rules and Rome rules in different shapes
and forms it's
shapeshifting yes and so we have a
little different prescription we know
that there is a progression in time
because the 10 horns hadn't been
established in the time of pagan Rome
they later became prominent then the the
crowns moved moved to the horns he ruled
over them the other interesting thing
about this Martin is that if you go to
the Book of Daniel you start with
Babylon then you go to Meer Persia then
you go to Greece and then you go to Rome
and then you go to paper Ro now here you
have it in reverse because what you see
is the leopard which is Greece you have
the bear which is me of Persia and and
you have the lion which is Babylon
that's it so you have the reverse so
here we are in a point of History where
you're looking back yes all of this has
already happened all already happened
you're looking at it in the reverse
sequence it's all already happened so we
are sure that we are not dealing with
different creatures we're dealing with
the sequence in time yes that's very
important that we understand that
Revelation 13:3 and I saw one of his
heads as it were wounded to death so in
other words it somehow in one of its
states lost its power but it's very
interesting that it say as it
were wounded to death why doesn't it
just say one of his heads was wounded to
death because it's not dead it's not
dead because this this Beast still
exists yeah so it seemed like a mortal
wound it seemed like a mortal wound and
then we have another progression the
deadly wound was healed and all the
world wandered after the Beast so there
is a seeming
death and there is a resurrection that's
also a progression in time exactly
Revelation is taking us through a
progression in time with different
phases of the same entity and power and
that's what's important because people
start
applying that progression to different
entities you can't and also very
important Martin is you cannot bring in
other entities you cannot in this
scenario say okay how does China fit in
here you can't do that you can't say how
does turkey fit in here yeah you can't
say how does Palestine fit in here
nothing because we are dealing with this
Roman entity that's what we're looking
at yeah so the one of the heads was
wounded so it received a mortal wound
when did the papacy receive a mortal
wound MH that 17 historically 1798 its
power was taken away its political power
but the
church for a while seemed to have lost
its power but it didn't actually lose
its power we'll get back to that and
this wound will be healed in other words
the power that it wielded when the
crowns were upon the horns will be given
back to
it so it will become prescriptive again
over the
horns and if you do that then you're
actually worshiping the dragon which
gave power unto the
Beast and they worship the Beast saying
who is like unto the Beast who is able
to make war with him so what else can we
glean from this well what we can glean
Martin is that if you follow the
dictates of this Beast you are more
obedient to it than you are to the god
of the Bible for sure right
yeah and the other question who is able
to make war with
him he must have some power that he
yields if if that is the question it
actually is a statement to say that no
one can make war with him no one he's
got everything in his power now this is
interesting
because this entity has no military
power except a small little Swiss
God and surely that is not going to move
a nation no so where does it get its
power from and how does it wield it mhm
and it's pretty sure that it has the
power of course because it says you
can't touch me I'll I'll obliterate you
right exactly all right nobody can make
war against it we also learned something
else that in the progression of
time they've picked up certain nuances
that
improved their
power uh if you take Daniel for example
the Daniel chapter Two the whole
progression is depicted as Metals yeah
in the Statue and you go from gold to
Silver to bronze to
iron now the value drops but the
strength
increases that's important gold is less
valuable than silver is less valuable
than bronze is less valuable than iron
but they get harder and they get
stronger it's interesting that even in
their military attire they followed that
pattern now this Beast has the
attributes of the leopard we've
discussed this many times before as well
and the leopard of course stood for
Greece Greece philosoph according to
Daniel and he defines it so you can't
guess it's just a fact
so the philosophy of this power is Greek
philosophy well we've discussed that the
whole of natural law everything is based
on Greek
philosophy even the question of Origins
correct comes from Aristotle the bear is
Meo Persian the system of governance is
a mraa system which is Meo
Persian and then the lion this is the
way he speaks is Babylonian
it's a Works based religion and it has
mother and child Worship in it for
example and this Beast is in other words
a progression from Pagan Rome to papal
Rome with authority transferred from the
heads to the horns that's
it let's
continue here's an interesting statement
that comes from the book Middle East
ferments by Louie F where he says today
incredible as it may seem many
Protestant preachers are now teaching
that the god inspired interpretations of
Prophecy so forcefully presented by the
reformers and which were the Bull workk
of the Protestant movement are
erroneous and that hence the reformers
untruthful exeresis of scripture was the
main stay of the foundation of the great
godsent ref
in other words the Reformation is
finished it's
useless according to what these many
Protestant preachers say because
nowadays they're sitting in ecumenical
councils they think that this power that
the Bible describes as the of
Revelation is a Christian power when
actual fact it's a pagan power
masquerading as a Christian
power and the reformers said that the
beasts of Revelation 13 pointed to the
papacy they said that the little horn
power in Daniel pointed to the papacy
and they had very sound exes as to why
they said so today that's not Bel no
they either believe preterism or
futurism most of them futurism the
Antichrist is coming in the
future but if he was already active in
Paul's day how can he come in the
future so it's a very great deception
then he asked the question how did this
change come about how did how did the
whole of the Protestant World change its
doctrines who did it the answer is clear
and decisive the
Jesuits the Jesuits this is what it's
about the Jesuits so in the Woodwork we
have to find the Jesuits undermining
every Protestant principle undermining
the doctrines of the Bible undermining
righteousness by faith undermining every
single tenant of the
atonement who's behind it the Jesuits
they are the most evil organization that
has ever existed and that will ever
exist and they are
sworn to the papacy yeah they will kill
murder do whatever it takes to further
the aims of the
papacy what is she hiding this
woman what does she not want you to see
let's let's see whether there's a
further
progression so you have this woman with
a golden
cup it's the Roman Catholic Church there
can be no doubt she depicts herself in
that
way in verse six it says and I saw the
woman drunken with the blood of the
Saints and with the blood of the martyrs
of Jesus and when I saw her I wondered
with great
admiration Millions upon Millions
hundreds of Millions have been
slaughtered the valenzas the alenas the
Protestants you can start before the
Reformation 100 years before the ran
Reformation with the hites you you name
it blood
flowed children were ripped from the
wombs there is no doubt that this
persecuting power continued what Rome
started in the coliseums yeah and did it
in another way and she used the most
terrible tortures in her torture
chambers and she is literally a church
drunk with the blood of the
martyrs and when I saw her I wondered
with great
admiration how can this be how can it
happen because the the way she portrays
herself looks so good looks so good and
the angel said unto me wherefore did
thou
Marvel I will tell thee The Mystery of
the woman so there's a mystery yeah and
of the Beast that carries her which has
seven heads and 10 horns the Beast that
thou sawest was
mhm pointing back in time so it's
pointing back to Revelation chapter 13
yeah and if you want to go beyond that
it's pointing back to Revelation chapter
12 so this Beast
was and is not m mhm so at this stage
when this prophecy takes place while the
angels are getting ready to pour out
their vs already historically
speaking she is in a is not
stage and shall Ascend out of the
bottomless
pit and go into
ption and they that dwell on the Earth
shall
wonder whose names were not written in
The Book of Life from the foundations of
the world and when they behold the Beast
that was and is not and yet is
MHM this is like a a riddle isn't it it
is it's a beautiful riddle so let's
unpack it this Beast once was a
political power now the interesting
thing is this Beast has no crowns no no
Revelation 17 no crowns Revelation 12
the crowns one head yeah Revelation 13
the crowns were on the horns now there
are no crowns because she is not
ruling oh let's put that differently
Martin She's appearing not to rule
exactly that is part of the mystery but
obviously she's ruling because he's
riding the beast the Beast exactly now
who controls the Reigns when you ride
the Beast the one sitting on top the one
who's sitting on top
right here she is ruling now how many
how many heads does this Beast have
seven seven does the woman have a head
yes so it's eight so if you add her head
what is her number again eight what was
the number of the little horn eight yes
obviously right cuz there were 10 three
were uprooted that leave seven and then
she takes prominence so she's the eighth
mhm here this woman is also the eighth
head is it the same as the little horn
same power
okay this is this is such an interesting
puzzle and you know mankind has been
trying to unravel this for many many
times and there are many many exes on
who the heads are some start with Egypt
and some start with a Syria and uh you
know who you leaving out and who you
putting in it's very complicated so
let's stick to what the scriptures said
yeah make it plain yes now you know
Martin I like
reading and sometimes you read a lot of
things that don't make much sense and
sometimes you read a lot of things that
make a lot of sense but are so
complicated that you can't unravel them
and have so many nuances so if you read
some of the symposiums what does this
one say what does that one say you know
you can get so entangled that later on
you think well nobody's ever going to
figure this out really and then
sometimes you come across something very
plainly and simply put and you think to
yourself you know maybe you don't always
have to go and drink at the well of the
theologians maybe you can just drink at
some other Wells as well and see if you
can see some pattern and then you have
your own ideas as well of course that's
it there are a couple of books that have
been reading lately and they're very
very
simple but I find them actually quite
enlightening I read a
book by Steve
Walberg the bloody woman and the seven
headed beast
M it's a short little
book
and it's very logically
written his idea is if you're talking
about all of these heads why don't you
stick to the heads yeah as Daniel and
Revelation gives them why do you want to
include other entities
and I thought it was a nice idea and I
said well thanks Steve nice little
thoughts let's M that one over and think
about it and then someone gave me this
book over here also a thinnish little
book so you will believe it's by Regan
Brett
cuk now I know the
kukes and I was thinking well I wonder
what they're saying cuz I know that I
know them personally some I know very
well of the confuses and some I don't
know so well but I thought to myself
well read it and you know I I am
pleasantly surprised because there are
some gems in it so some of these little
books one can recommend just to give a a
nice picture just a nice new little
simple summary yeah of something that's
actually very complicated so not
deviating from anything that's there
it's actually just putting it back into
Easy's perspective and there's another
book that uh I read many many years ago
already and I found it very very
thorough the king of the north at
Jerusalem by Louie fwar and some people
have decided that they're going to throw
Lou if wear out the
window because they think is this that
or the other but if you just follow the
logic of what he is saying I find it
rather profound I'm just saying for
Simplicity sake it's sometimes nice to
read something that is very
straightforward and to the point yeah
and I think there's some Merit in what
what they are
saying all right so let's look at this
this beast and what its attributes are
he said why did you Marvel I will tell
you this mystery of the woman and of the
Beast that carries her which has seven
heads and 10 horns the Beast that thou
sawest was pointing back to when it had
power and is not this is the time frame
that we're talking about so what time
frame are we talking about this beast at
the moment is not wielding power or
doesn't seem to be wielding power
exactly so it's after it had received
the socalled deadly wound so it must be
after 1798 right so we're living in a
time of history from
1798 to where we are now yeah so we are
in the E not stage and it shall Ascend
out of the bottomless pit so we want to
know what philosophy mhm came out of the
bottomless pit because that's where it
comes from
yeah and where's it going to go well
it's going to go to ition so this Beast
is going to be destroyed
yeah and uh who follows it they that
dwell on the Earth shall wonder where
did we pick up that word before the
Wonder after the beast in Revelation
chapter 133 and the word Wonder with a o
yeah means that you receive its mindset
you think about it and you think that
this Beast is right it's actually
deceiving you
yeah because those that Wonder after it
in other words accept its
wine are not written in the book of life
and that's puts it very clear who these
people are big trouble so you better
look at them very
carefully and they beheld the Beast that
was and is not this is the stage we're
in now and yet it is it is so so how can
it not be if it
is it must have gone underground right
mhm so let's look at that this is
fascinating and here is the mind which
has
wisdom uh Daniel says None of the wicked
will understand but the wise will
understand and the wise will have their
names in the book not like the other
ones now what makes you wise your
intelligence no definitely not no your
wisdom comes from believing the word of
God that's where I remember when you
mentioned that that's where Holiness
comes from in agreement and if you
believe the word of God and you don't do
it you're a hypocrite yeah okay so
here's the mind which has wisdom the
seven heads are seven
mountains now this is a
clear description yeah exactly you don't
have to wonder when the Bible in Daniel
says there are 10 horns
and these 10 horns are 10 kings that
shall arise or 10
kingdoms gives both definitions and
that's what they are yeah so here are
seven mountains so it gives you the
literal description all right so there
are seven mountains there are literal
mountains is Rome built on seven
mountains or Seven Hills mhm yes but a
mountain in scripture also stands for a
kingdom yes so she is
built on seven inclusive Kingdom so if
you if we take it into the historic
continuous interpretation this will be
following on each other in
SE and then it tells you where we are in
the Stream of time and there are seven
Kings remember that a kingdom also has a
king MH five are
Fallen one is the other is not yet come
and when he comes he must continue for a
short
space all right five are Fallen we'll
have to see who the five are that are
Fallen the one
is which one is the is not stage because
that's what he described as it is in the
is not stage and the other is not yet
come so there's one to come and when he
comes he must continue a short space
fortunately only a short space space we
don't have to sit with them for very
long and then it has this interesting
verse and the Beast that was and is not
it's in the E not stage even he is the
eighth yeah and he is of the seven and
goes into petion now he's the
eighth uh once the three horns W
uprooted what was the little horn then
the eth and if you if this woman with
her head sits on a seven-headed beast
and she has a head then what is her
number eight okay so eight becomes
interesting right
yes so if we use only the beasts as
portrayed in Daniel and Revelation in
other words we cut out all the other
possibilities with the many exer jesuses
that there are out there in the world we
don't count Egypt we don't count uh
Assyria we don't count any of them we
only what Daniel and Revelation has
given China Russia leave them out leave
them all out just look at what Daniel
and Revelation has said then the five
that have fallen at this stage are
Babylon met Persia Greece and Rome yeah
Pagan Rome
right and paper Rome that's it because
she's the is not stage exactly she
received IM mortal room yes after 17
those five that have fallen one
is yeah that must be in the wounded
papacy because there no crowns on any of
their heads or
horns that seemed to have a mortal wound
and was
ruling because it's riding the beast it
must be ruling via a proxy yeah so it's
still ruling but you don't know you
don't know who it's ruling it's closing
its eyes you're not supposed to see this
right cuz she's supposed to be out of
sight yes out of sight out of mind and
if the Antichrist has been identified
what if the Antichrist doesn't exist
anymore and has no power then he's not a
problem there must be another Antichrist
maybe were wrong yeah and then he still
has to come or whatever oh yeah he still
has to go maybe he was already there
then we don't have to worry about
him but he's going to be destroyed by
the brightness of his coming how could
he have been already there yeah or maybe
he's coming in the future then and if
it's only the future one what about he
is big problem all right so if she's
riding then the Beast exists and the
Beast is a political power right one is
that must be the wounded papacy that
seemed to have a mortal wound and was
ruling via a
proxy the Mortal wound was administered
in 1798 by France France also introduced
an atheistic Godless form of secular
government during the French reol
reolution
and it attacked the two witnesses of God
the old and the New Testament and we
read all of that in Revelation chapter
11 we don't want to do a full exeresis
of Revelation 11 now we don't have time
we're concentrating on this woman yes
but let's just go to the verse
Revelation
11:7 and when they that's the two
witnesses the old and the New Testament
finish their
testimony the Beast ascended out of the
bottomless pit shall make war against
them and shall overcome them and kill
them so firstly this Beast this power
which is not described as anything as a
seven-headed beast or anything it's just
called a beast it's a political entity
yeah and it comes out of the bottomless
pit M this woman of Revelation 17 wasn't
she also associated with the bottomless
pit exactly so what's a philosophy in
the E not state
the philos in a wounded stage it must be
secularism it must be what came out of
the French Revolution right mhm okay so
who actually rules after
1798 well Revelation 13 tells us there's
a beast out of the Earth yeah and this
Beast has two phases just like Rome had
a pagan phase and a Papal
phase so so the Beast has two phases it
has a lambl likee phase and a phase that
speaks like a dragon that's there is no
conquering here it's a shift yeah it's
the same as there's no
ruling by the other one it's just a
shift in shape correct and there are no
crowns because it's a is not stage yeah
but it's still ruling still ruling this
woman is riding this Beast like it or
not even in the not stage yeah and I
beheld another Beast come up out of the
earth and he had two horns like a lamb
and he spake as a dragon now we know
what the dragon speaks like he
persecutes yeah he makes laws against
Gods against God's people yeah and he
kills them so this lambik Beast is going
to speak like the dragon he going to
speak like Rome spoke yeah and he
exercises all the power of the first
Beast before him who's his proxy the
United States of America this beast
that's it because he's doing exactly
what this one that is not supposedly
wants him to do in any case but Martin
it's a llike beast it's a Protestant
country are you telling me that this
woman is using this power as a proxy to
rule in her behalf so that people won't
see
her but in actual fact she's still
ruling that's exactly what the Bible is
telling us
okay and what does this Beast do when it
speaks like the dragon it causes the
Earth and them that dwell therein to
worship the first beast in other words
to honor and obey it that's it how do
you do that by forcing how do you force
them legislation okay whose deadly wound
was healed so there's a progression
until this deadly wound is healed yeah
this Beast is acting as a proxy for the
other one that's it all right and you
will start seeing it speaking like a
dragon the closer we get to the he
transition from a lambik principle to a
dragon principle but Martin if it was a
proxy then the dragon principle must
have been hidden in it all along yeah
definitely from the beginning
okay how how do you deal and
Rule without being
seen smoke screens smoke screen okay
secret societies and
confederacies as we near the close of
time there will be greater and still
greater external parade of heathen power
Heathen deities will manifest their
signal power and will exhibit themselves
before the cities of the world and this
delineation has already begun to be
fulfilled when did it start well it
started in 1844 already with the fox
sisters and spiritism and Heathen
deities in other words that's demons
manifesting themselves yeah and it will
happen more and more So eventually
they'll take over churches and what is
called the working of the holy spirit is
actually a demonic power oh very very
serious by a variety of imag is the Lord
Jesus represented to John that's the
Revelation the wicked character and
seductive influence of those who have
been distinguished for their persecution
of God's people it's talking about Rome
in both the Pagan form and paper and the
paper form sure all need wisdom
carefully to search out the mystery of
iniquity that figures so largely in the
winding up of this Earth's history we
need to look look at
this that mystery of iniquity now where
do we find it this terrible picture
drawn by John to show how completely the
powers of Earth will give themselves
over to evil should show those who have
received the truth how danger it is to
link up with secret societies or to join
themselves in anyway with those who do
not keep God's Commandments Mar do you
think secret societies are playing a
role in all of this I think it's the the
main players must be the role players
that's the role players but it's also
interesting that you're not allowed in
any way to join yourself to those that
don't keep the commandments so the
Commandments are the pivot as to who
you're worshiping and if you really want
to know who you're worshiping the
Sabbath becomes pivotal exactly all
right so do secret societies have
something to do with the revelation of
John yes I think it's pivotal well from
this statement you can't separate them
right there's not no way you can
separate them let's read another one
from eight manuscripts releases God's
presentation of the detestable works of
the inhabitants of the ruling powers of
the world who bind themselves in secret
societies and confederacies not honoring
the law of God should enable the people
who have the light of Truth to keep
clear of these evils so Martin if you
have the light of the
truth would you then consider that the
kings of the world have bound themselves
in secret societies yes you will and if
you can find out who these secret
societies are would you distance
yourself from you have to otherwise
you're lost right otherwise you get part
of this whole thing that will be
destroyed okay now who's involved all
those not honoring the law of
God so you should keep clear of these
evils more and more will all false
religionists of the world manifest their
evil doings for there are but two
parties those who keep the Commandments
of God and those who war against God's
holy law they only two to why is there
so much Confusion by bringing in all of
these entities from
outside and who's particularly involved
the false religionists yes so religious
systems are they bound up in secret
societies all of them aren't they mainly
Masons yeah aren't they Freemasons yeah
aren't they Knights of Malta aren't they
Knights of Columbus all of them they're
either in the Catholic institutions or
they think they are in Protestants
institutions but the Protestant
institutions are actually run by other
institutions without them
knowing in plain sight
yeah so let's go back into this history
where does it come from it comes out of
this bottomless pit that happened during
the French Revolution yeah so that's
secularism and all those things that's
directly opposed to the Commandments
okay so Daniel chapter
11:40 says and at the time of the end
shall the King of the South push at him
so the King of the South will push at
him push at whom at the King of the
North yeah now who is the King of the
North the King of the North is the
papacy now there are people that want to
argue and say the King of the North is
not the papacy it's turkey mhm uh turkey
submitted itself to the British rule
yeah and became part and parcel of NATO
and the European nations it is not a
separate Ottoman Empire any longer it is
part of NATO
and Louis of we
summarizes what the uh early Pioneers
believed on the issue now some want to
discredit him but you know you can't
discredit what uh the scriptures teach
yeah and what the Pioneers taught yeah
so if he quotes something of a
Pioneer yes then you can't discredit him
you have to go back to the pioneer as
well now he's talking about James White
and uh we know that UAH Smith stood for
the idea that the King of the North was
turkey and condemning The View that
turkey was the power referred to in
Daniel
114-45
James White wrote an editorial in the
review in Herald on November the 29th
1877 he said let us take a brief view of
the line of Prophecy four times spanned
in the Book of Daniel it will be a
admitted that the same ground is passed
over in Chapter 2 7 8 and
11 with this exception that Babylon is
left out of chapters 8 and
11 we first pass down the great image of
chapter 2 where
Babylon Persia Greece and Rome are
represented by the gold silver and brass
and iron all
agree that these feet are not Turkish
but Roman
it has to be okay then he continues and
he makes a statement that's James White
James White makes the statement now
comes the point in the argument upon
which very much
depends does the 11th chapter of the
prophecy of Daniel cover the ground
measured by chapters 27 and 8 mhm if so
then the last power mentioned in that
chapter is Rome it cannot if you you
continuously showed that those are the
it's shown in those chapters you cannot
even all of a sudden change it he
continues to say if the legs of iron and
the feet of iron and clay in the second
chapter represent
Rome and if the nondescript 10 horned
beast and the little Horn of the seventh
chapter represent
Rome and if the little horn which waxed
exceeding great of the eighth chapter
represents r
the King of the North represents Rome
also these are four parallel prophecies
Brethren reaching down to the coming of
Our Lord now if that is what James White
wrote and I believe it is eminently
logical yeah then let us stick to what
Revelation is telling us and let us not
jump to confusions and bring in turkey
or China or Russia or whoo oever or Iran
we're talking about the powers of Europe
that's what the prophecy is about let's
stick to it I agree maybe two points the
one we've mentioned it before yes Alan
white wrote against what the way that
James White took on riah Smith about
that por but he didn't condemn what he
said what he said
secondly if you just take the book of
the Great controversy nowhere do you
read that in the end this time that any
part will be played by turkey no it's
played by the papac so let's not get
confused by these false interpretations
that are coming into our midst so at the
time of the end
Martin shall the King of the South push
at him now the King of the South or
acting the role of of the King of the
South was France during the French
Revolution and the pope was taken
captive in
1798 so in 1798 bartier the French
general made his entrance into Rome and
abolished the papal government and
established a secular one so the crowns
were
removed he had no longer any power he
became an is not stage at as a political
entity this comes from the encyclopedia
Americana
Edition now let's go and look at the
role players yeah who was the role
player it was Napoleon the first now
here's a article from the Grand Lodge of
British Colombia and Yukon and they're
talking about Napoleon and
Freemasonry and they're saying the
question whether bonapar was a Freemason
or not has never been
decided rumor says he was made at Malta
some writers inclined to the belief that
he was only historically instructed the
only matter of certainty is that he
countenanced the institution and
astutely made it subserve his own
purposes and then I have this
interesting note
here
Napoleon and the French Revolution the
evidence in favor of a masonic
initiation previous to Napoleon's
Assumption of the Imperial title is
overwhelming and this is the lodge
speaking exactly I just wanted to
mention they normally enjoy to boast
about affiliations towards them all
right this intiation took place in the
body of an
army Philadelphia Lodge at acosia
primitive right of
narbon the third initiation of the EOL
communic being an advancement of that
right these initiations took place
between
1795 and
1798 so according to
Freemasonry uh does it seem that he was
associated with Freemasonry very much
okay let's continue this little historic
Saga continuing with the gr lodes
arguments so August 15
1769 to May 5th
1821 born Napoleon bonap PARTA in
Corsica and trained in military schools
in Paris Napoleon was promoted to
General after the siege of tulon in 1793
he led troops into most of Europe and in
1798 Egypt returning to France he was
nominated first Consul After the
Revolution so he conquered Egypt in 1798
yeah does he then become the king of
Egypt yes so when Revelation says this
place is called spiritually Egypt it's
in a literal sense and in a figurative
sense and if it says Sodom it means it's
Li
that's it was France lens oh very much
was it associated with Egypt yes all
right Napoleon founded the bank of
France reformed the tax system restored
the Church improved the education system
so if he restored the Church is the
woman alive and well that's it and she's
riding on some Beast which is a proxy
beast but nobody knows that she's
actually in control that's it so she's
Undercover but restored
ah so it changes the entire system of
governance right improved the education
system and in
184 assumed the hereditary title of
emperor of the French the following year
he was at war with Russia Austria and
England by April 1840 he was forced to
abdicate and exile to Alba he attempted
to regain his Empire in 185 15 but was
defeated at
waterl banished to St Helena he died 6
years later all right so he was removed
from from history but he did his job he
played a part it changed the entire
governing system of the entire
Europe right French Revolution the ideas
of the French Revolution so he was very
much a part of that movement to get the
crowns of the 10 horns yes so
actually literally removed the
crowns and the woman was still riding
the beast but she seemed to have no
power yeah all right now if he was a
Freemason then is there any other
evidence that he was a
Freemason well here's another
interesting source and it says that
Napoleon appointed his brothers to
Masonic office Louie was named Deputy
Grandmaster in 1805 Gerard was Grand
Master of the grand Orient West failure
the eldest Joseph was made a Freemason
at tulies in April 1805 and appointed
Grand Master of the grand Orient of
France and Lucien was a member of the
grand Orient of France so all of his
brothers became top
Masons was he involved in masonry well
if he put them there in that office
obviously he should have been eye up
obviously he was there so here's
something else that's interesting this
comes from the international Napoleonic
Society Napoleon was the first leader in
Europe to Grant Liberty equality and
fraternity to all
religions so when this power Rome ruled
when the crowns were on the horns which
religion had preeminence the Christ well
Christianity according to them papal
papal chrisal Christianity but by
1798 there were so many wars that had
taken place and protestantism had taken
a prominent Place MH and it seemed as if
the paple power was forever gone yeah
and in many places Rome had no power
whatsoever anymore had nothing to say
mhm how was it going to get that power
back so what if it disappeared yeah and
ruled from the bottomless pit exactly
with a bottomless pit philosophy without
anybody knowing it it will be a
brilliant strategy and if you have a
freedom of religion and Equity amongst
all religions then she can't be banned
ex that's exactly what happens so and
when you want to get if somebody is
banned like you mentioned and it's a
religious then just make all religions
acceptable again you put in back and off
you go all right so Liberty and equality
and fraternity for All in This
lithograph of the ground Napoleon is
granting Liberty to the Jews this is
what you see here on the left so
Napoleon's Uncle Cardinal fesh also got
involved he told Napoleon
sah so you wish the end of the world to
come with your laws to give the Jews
equality like
Catholics do you not know that the holy
scriptures predict that the end of the
world will happen when the Jews will be
recognized as a corporate nation is that
true or is that a false religion that's
a false interpretation of what's said in
the Bible because we've gone from
literal to spiritual Israel exactly and
the kingdom of God is being set up and
if you are in Christ you are Abraham's
seed so where does this philosophy come
from it's a jesuitical
philosophy that is being pushed here all
right now what if we can get the whole
world to believe this philosophy then we
must somehow re create the Jewish State
yes and then all eyes will be on
Jerusalem and then you and maybe you'll
believe that turkey is the King of the
North and be fooled into that yes
because that one has to destroy this one
and this this is going to happen and
who's off the hook then the papacy the
woman riding the beast is totally off
the hook and then you throw in that the
Antichrist is going to be in that state
in the temp can't be the Antichrist
can't be the Antichrist anymore so
here's a jesuitical philosophy that is
being pushed by
Napoleon all right let's sum this up for
religion Napoleon entered the Schism and
restored the Catholic Church to France
by the concordat in
1801 he ensured freedom of religion and
equality to the Protestant sects now
there's no enemy anymore right so
everybody is happy now because they all
got their place in the Sun and he
declared France the homeland of the Jews
m
after it became obvious he could not
establish their National home in
Palestine the code Napoleon established
equality before the law emphasized the
sanctity of the family does it sound
like a modern philosophy assured the
legal gains of the Revolution the code
of civil procedures ensured widespread
user of mediation in courts and laws and
the courts were
secularized is that the state St quoe
today yes is this the is not stage form
of government
definitely okay who's riding this Beast
still Rome still the woman so Napoleon's
religious opinions were the height of
modern philosophy he was completely
given to tolerance everywhere that
Napoleon went he led tolerance by the
hand everywhere he found several
religions he entered the domination
which one took precedence over the other
Faith Napoleon would say is beyond the
reach of the law it is the most personal
possession of man and no one has the
right to demand an account for it sounds
good yeah it sounds very lamb likee this
tolerance is tolerating everybody's
opinion or the religion now what if this
tolerance is only for a time until this
Beast has achieved its purpose oh for
sure it's definitely because then it
will come up again what if it even
though it seems right can be used for a
wrong
purpose
okay let's continue with this
history now here's an amazing incident
which is not generally known when the
French troops were in Palestine and
besieging the City of akre
Napoleon had already prepared a
proclamation making Palestine an
independent Jewish state did you know
that
no he was unable to realize this project
because of the intervention of the
British this Proclamation was printed
and dated the 20th of April 1799 just
after the Mortal wound right after but
his unsuccessful attempt to capture arre
prevented it from being issued the Jews
had to wait more than 150 years before
their state was proclaimed the
proclamation however did bear fruit it
was a precursor to
Zionism heightening awareness of the
cause of the Jewish statehood now m is
that a deception or is that biblical
it's a deception whose deception that
Jesuits that
Jesuits the idea Napoleon expressed
found the admiration of many who saw
Napoleon's gesture as a fulfillment of
biblical prophecy the many are the
Jesuits who want to take the Heat of the
papacy is the
Antichrist because futurism and
preterism come from the pens of the
Jesuit yes to take the heat off which
for tells of the restoration of the Jews
to their land the idea grew many
adherence especially in England and also
be at 1798 at that stage the Jesuits
were banned in most places yes now all
of this comes from ww Napoleon series.
all 108 years later the British would
issue the Bal for declaration which
called for a Jewish homeland and
ultimately 31 years later in 8
1948 Israel would be recognized as a
sovereign state by popular vote in the
United Nations General Assembly perhaps
it can be said that Napoleon's premature
announcement on that first day of
Passover in
1799 played an important part in the
creation of the state of of Israel on
the 16th of August 1800 Napoleon
declared if I governed a nation of Jews
I should reestablish the Temple of
Solomon the Martin here you have a
jesuitical
ideology being placed into the
Protestant mindset yes to totally remove
the mindset of the reformation and to
move the heat totally from the papal and
now you have people that are looking at
Israel and Turkey instead of looking at
Rome and what the papacy is doing and
they are and they should be looking at
the Beast out of the out of the Sea and
the Beast out of the earth and what is
this woman doing clandestinely riding
another Beast so let's go into that with
a little bit of of uh
investigation so we have a totally false
system of religion yeah that has taken
the place of protestantism
and the Jesuits have played a masterly
game how did they do it well we'll have
to find out we'll have to find out shall
we do that in a second session because I
think people's heads are spinning now
already let's do that Amen Let let's
pray Heavenly
Father what an amazing
story and it's all there in the Book of
Revelation and in the Book of
Daniel what a wonderful gift help us to
understand it better in jesus' name amen
[Music]
amen